et de et le nucléaire il a parlé au
jeudi mais vous avez vu le culot alors
le nucléaire pour les téléspectateurs ça
serait quoi voilà pour le nucléaire
c'est il arme de destruction massive
sellam larmes qui me fait peur c'est
larmes qui n'a jamais été utilisée était
utilisé sauf qu'une seule fois par les
américains en 1945
contre les japonais radieux reprise donc
et un schéma et nagasaki et pour
utiliser sa contre l'ukraine et il
pourrait utiliser ça au début quand on
l'ukraine mais ce qui est inquiétant
c'est ce même pas ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il a dit je mène pas la
guerre contre l'ukraine je mène la
guerre contre vous à l'occident temps
l'occident c'est ça c'est tout
l'occident qui est derrière et je
considère lui enfin lui il considère que
c'est tout l'occident qui lui fait le
lézard donc comme vous avez dit les
états unis en premier lieu les états
membres et la grande beauté allemagne
l'allemagne la france etc et est donc ça
c'est la première chose inquiétante et
de toute façon donc les armes nucléaires
si jamais les emplois c'est ce sera la
première fois en 60 ans et c'est une
arme dans lesquels on sait comment on
part on sait plus comment s'arrête
et moi j'avais j'avais un tout petit peu
d'espoir hier hier la dent dans la
soirée parce qu'ils devaient se
prononcer prononcer ce discours hier à
20h heure de moscou et puis ils annulent
et puis tout personne ne comprend
pourquoi ils annulent peut-être qu'il a
changé d'avis peut-être il est tué
peut-être qu'il ya quelque chose
peut-être il est emprisonné peut être il
ya les généraux qui ont compris qu'ils
ont faire un coup d'état donc il y avait
des spéculations hier toute la soirée et
toute la nuit j'ai quasiment pas dormi
cette nuit j'attendais qu'est ce qu'il
disait est ce qu'il ya une fuite qui va
sortir en disant que finalement une en
prison ça y est c'est terminé la guerre
est terminée et ce matin il prononce son
discours est donc dur très dur très dur
donc en plus au nucléaire ou ça vous
savez que le clos avec lequel il raconte
ça il dit l'ukraine a fait la tentative
d'acquérir l'armé nucléaire attendez
l'ukraine n'a pas d'armes nucléaires
l'ukraine à la sortie dure et c'est ce
avait les armes nucléaires elle a
préféré mais donner à la russie
donc elle a signé un accord qui
s'appelle l'accord de budapest en
1994 et la russie lui garantissait sa
sécurité
et ce mec-là est là le culot de dire les
ukrainiens me menace de nuit parce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire aussi
c'est que une guerre pourrait éclater
entre la russie et notamment la france
le truc c'est que s'ils ce qui pourrait
se passer là c'est à dire tu ferais quoi
il enverrait le sait quoi ça va jouer
dans les chroniques dans les prochains
jours ça peut jouer n'importe quand là
on est on est on est on est vraiment
dans donc je ne voudrais pas faire peur
mais la situation est vraiment vraiment
difficile bien sûr ça veut dire que en
fait lui il est acculé acculé il a
compris et les généraux ont compris un
russe qu'il ne perd pas qu'ils ne
peuvent pas vacances et de l'ukraine et
donc à on espérait qu'ils le comprennent
et qu'ils disent la guerre est finie on
signe la paix avec les ukrainiens
l'accord les sanctions tombent et c est
lui à la place de ça alors il nous sort
ça se sent pas ça il va vouloir gagner
la guerre coûte voilà donc voilà donc la
caisse qui feraient ils enverraient
d'abord il attaquera avec le nucléaire
l'ukraine d'abord en principe il peut
employer ce qu'on appelle le nucléaire
tactique
d'accord c'est à dire contre le cren
tactique ça venir c'est une petite bombe
nucléaire
celle qui qui était qui était employé à
hiroshima et nagasaki
ces 15 kilotonnes 15 20 kilotonnes la
science 20 kilotonnes ça détruit une
ville de 50 mille habitants ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé pour eux donc
on fait ça détruit disons un territoire
de 5 km totalement et puis ça fait les
dégâts or avec 10 km 15 km auto et ça
pour vous c'est une petite ça c'est
hiroshima mais
bombes nucléaires tactiques c'est plus
petit que ça oui c'est plus ça peut
détruire un kilomètre avec les dégâts 5
km autour et puis radiations qui va
rester quelques semaines deux trois
quatre semaines sur place et donc
continuer à tuer les gens avec la
radiation ça c'est la même tactique et
donc par exemple et peut me faire sur la
capitale de l'ukraine kiev
lancé sur le palais présidentiel la
williams zelensky mai et donc ça
détruira le quartier dans lequel se
trouve ce palais et
quelle serait la réaction internationale
je crois que la poutine ne se rend pas
compte en fait il est
devenu fou en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est enfermé complètement dans sa bulle
il ne comprend plus rien qui se passe et
commence à croire dans les mensonges
qu'il raconte et donc il est persuadé
que ce que ce qu'elle raconte est vrai
et donc il ne peut pas s'imaginer que si
jamais ils emploient ça c'est la ligne
rouge de toutes les lignes rouges ça
veut dire il deviendra par ya déjà la
russie subit les sanctions la ruse et
l'économie russe ne marche pas
contrairement à certains qui disent non
les échos les sanctions marchent plutôt
font mal chez nous ici plutôt qu'en
russie c'est faux la russie a déjà perdu
des capitaux il a perdu et déjà la
production le gasprom le fleuron aliaga
les gaziers et la production de pétrole
chute donc la russie souffre déjà